this video is sponsored by athletic
greens and to be honest with you this is
one that I'm really excited to talk
about athletic greens was kind enough to
send me a 30-day supply of ag-1 which is
an all-in-one nutritional drink that
does a lot of really awesome things for
your body like supporting your immunity
and improving your mood Focus gut health
energy and just a whole bunch more and
let me be honest with you this was
perfect for me because I'll admit I have
never had that healthy of a diet so
historically I've always struggled with
energy levels and such but speaking from
my heart after taking a minute to drink
ag1 in the mornings for more than 20
days now I sleep better I think better I
have more energy to work and go to the
gym every day and I just feel better and
it complies with any lifestyle choices
like keto or paleo or veganism so I've
even got a lot of my friends and family
members trying it out too whether you're
a homebody or an athlete I cannot
recommend drinking ag1 enough they have
a brand new long time subscriber in me
and if you're curious about improving
your health in pretty much every way
click my link in the description below
to get a one year supply of immune
boosting vitamin D3 K2 and 5 travel
packs for free with your first purchase
we've only got one life each so let's
take care of it yeah and now on to the
video tears of the kingdom is just over
100 days away and I'm sure you're
excited because everyone's excited and
if someone says they're not excited
they're lying they actually are excited
in our excitement though as I'm sure
you've noticed there have been no
shortage of speculations and theories
made about the upcoming Zelda game based
off of the few things we've been shown
about it in this video I'd like to add
yet another theory to that list but one
that I think could shed some light on
one of the most ambiguous and mysterious
characters in all of Zelda lore and that
would be the goddess hylia whose
existence was revealed to us when
Skyward Sword released in 2011 and uh
fun fact I guess this idea popped into
my head while I was making my previous
video explaining every Zelda in the
franchise so if you haven't seen that
video yet be sure to check it out after
you're done here now keep in mind that
just like any Theory this has in no way
been confirmed by Nintendo or anyone
affiliated with Nintendo butt for for a
lot of fans myself included this
mysterious long-eared figure shown in
the most recent tears of the Kingdom
trailer has a lot of reason to actually
be hylia herself however for the sake of
not being redundant I'm not going to go
into too much detail as far as that
particular theory is concerned I will
summarize it here of course and we'll
also link to my two-part theory that I
did with zeltic on the subject in the
description below if you'd like a deeper
look but in a nutshell the main thought
process behind this theory is as follows
the symbolism of seven tiers is similar
to hylia and her six sages the parallel
imagery between this figure and Zelda
herself seems to mimic the parallel
between hylia and Zelda and the figures
assumed connection to all the weird
green magic and therefore the figure's
magic being able to repair the master
sword which is something I assume is
happening since it's shown in the logo
to be repaired and literally rebuilt
from the green magic which is different
from Simply upgrading the master sword
in A Link to the Past and A Link Between
Worlds is something that you would
assume only hylia the creator of the
master sword could do there's also the
fact that this figure has a closed third
eye on its forehead which if it were to
open like the symbol on the back of
Link's new Shield would look a whole lot
like the Chica symbol who are famously
the people group known for being sworn
to you guessed it hylia and her
descendants and finally the figure
clearly has something to do with ancient
structures existing in the sky on these
Sky Islands or Sky rule as I like to
call it and believe it or not there are
even more details that we could go into
but that's the shell of the nut for this
video though I'd like to Branch off of
the idea that this is probably somehow
hylia the goddess if you don't like that
assumption then you're probably not
going to like the rest of this video but
anyway the next theory that I'd like to
make following up on this figure being
hylia is a simple one but it has to do
with the question of the figure's
strange appearance I mean just look at
it it doesn't have very humanoid facial
features in fact it looks like it kind
of has a pointed animal nose the biggest
Oddity however has got to be the ears
which are massive and you'd think are
therefore very telling about just what
species this figure is supposed to be
the arms are also pretty long All Things
Considered like if they were stretched
out they would drag on the ground my
point with all of this is that clearly
this figure is not very human in fact
I'd say it's obviously not so the
question is what is it and is it a new
species of being that we've yet to see
in the franchise or is it something
we've already seen of course it could
always be something new but I actually
think it could be a Minish you heard me
a little Minish person from the sky but
before you assume this is just a load of
garbage hear me out this is gonna make a
weird sort of sense by the time I'm done
since we were already talking about
appearance let's start there right off
the bat the large eyes the pointed
animalistic knows the giant ears and
long arms match almost exactly diminish
are always shown wearing little caps of
course but I'm sure if this were the
goddess hylia there could be an
exception made to the headwear
especially if it were to show off
luscious locks of hair and as a reminder
breath of the wild did not introduce a
single new species to the world of Zelda
think about it from Monsters to
hyruleans every single species of living
being in the game is from a previous
game and given that there were already
proven plans to include diminish in
breath of the wild it would make all too
much sense to finally include them in
tears of the Kingdom but let's put a pin
on the appearance argument for now which
is shallow at best and talk about how
this could make sense from a deeper lore
perspective the weirdest things about
the Minish that I've always found
strange and kind of hard to explain
would be one their connection to the
hylians who live on the surface of
Hyrule and two their gifts specifically
one evil sealing sword and one unlimited
golden Power known as the light force or
simply as the Force in Japanese also I
want to point out that according to an
interview with hirimaru fujibayashi who
directed the Minish Cap the light force
is specifically not confirmed to be
related to the Triforce at all meaning
its origin is more than likely from
something or someone else anyway
everyone who knows the story of the
Minish Cap knows that the Minish gave
these gifts to hylians long before the
events of the game but nobody asks why
or how how are the Minish even capable
of making a golden Power like this and
why would they gift it to the hylians
well if hylia was a member of the Minish
then that could answer these two
questions let's hop over to the opening
cut scene of Skyward Sword real quick
and compare for some possible insights
according to the game long ago the dark
Forces of demise and his demons
assaulted the land and brought
destruction and murder everywhere they
went as they chased after the Triforce
the goddess who we know as hylia
defended the Triforce and the living
hyruleans from the dark Forces remember
this is told to us as an ancient legend
in Skyward Sword which is already the
most ancient game on the timeline
meaning it took place a long time before
skyward Swords surrounded by events that
are otherwise undocumented and therefore
wide open to speculation similarly the
opening cutscene of the Minish Cap which
is the game that takes place right after
Skyward Sword also states that a long
long time ago when the world was on the
verge of being swallowed by Shadow the
pcori aka the Minish descended from the
sky and gave mankind the two gifts now
these two stories don't sync up exactly
but they have a lot in common both are
ancient legends of already ancient games
both detail a World Under Siege of
darkness and both entail an intervention
of light or forces of the light so
here's my thought process what if these
two stories are actually one and the
same stay with me we're getting
somewhere remember that specifically
before the events of Skyward Sword which
includes before the era in the past that
demise is freed from as shown in game
way back when hylia initially fought
demise she had a chosen hero what if
hylia's unknown chosen hero was the hero
of men that the opening of the Minish
Cap talks about and furthermore what if
the golden light that was given to
Hyrule was in fact hylia herself and
this light that shown above her head is
specifically animated differently from
the light that's supposed to depict the
Triforce surrounded by particles meaning
this Golden Light Above hylia's head
probably comes from hylia herself a
golden Power furthermore and this is
probably the biggest evidence for this
connection of them all the golden light
aka the light force was placed inside
the bloodline of hyrule's princesses
where it remains presumably to this day
so now that we've talked about the
possible connected lore between these
two games let me provide an explanation
for what could have happened that ties
these stories together notice that the
first event that takes place in both
stories is the assault of dark Forces so
what if this really is what happened
first demise and his demons emerged from
a shadowy fissure within the Earth to
gain the Triforce at this point the
Minish goddess hylia who was entrusted
by the golden goddesses to protect the
Triforce descended to the surface
bringing with her her own sword called
The Goddess sword a golden light which
is her own power and another sword
called the pcori blade for her chosen
hero this is also one of the only ways
to explain the existence and
similarities between the pcori blade
which is an evil ceiling blade and the
master sword which is also an evil
ceiling Blade the two swords even look
extremely similar to one another as if
they were crafted by the same people
albeit being used for slightly different
purposes she then sent the surviving
humans into the sky where she came from
by the power of her Golden Light for
their own protection now if the this
were to be the case or anything close to
the case that's one thing you're
probably wondering what this has to do
with the strange figure presumably
Minish hylia shown in the tears of the
Kingdom trailer to answer that question
I think it has something to do with the
fact that Zelda is going to potentially
be killed in the game remember that
aunuma famously said that what's
happening in this cave sequence in tears
of the kingdom is going to be even
darker than Majora's Mask and Zelda has
not been shown in the trailer since
falling so should a Zelda be killed for
the first time in the franchise that we
know of what if Hailey's Spirit
manifests itself once again in her
original Minish form and what if finding
a way to resurrect Zelda by working
alongside the spirit of hylia and
collecting her seven tiers is the entire
point of the game now I will be the
first to admit that this theory is far
from foolproof for instance hylia's
image shown to us in Skyward Sword and
in her statues in both Skyward Sword and
breath of the wild look nothing like the
figure from tears of the kingdom and
while the Skyward Sword and Minish
Legends are similar they do have
different endings where in Skyward Sword
hylia Saves the Day by Sealing demise
away and in the Minish Cap the hero of
Men saves the day by sealing the
monsters away that being said though it
is possible that hylia's appearance
changed pre-skywood sword due to her
creating a new humanoid appearance which
would then be referred to as Hylian and
she wouldn't be the only Minish in the
series to become bigger and humanoid
looking as that's also something that
vati famously does as well and with how
they get similar these two backstories
are and how they seem to fill one
another's gaps and how underused the
Minish are in the franchise and hylia's
and the minish's shared obsession with
the sky and breath of the Wild's
tendency to bring back Niche pieces of
the Zelda universe and the connections
to highly un alarmingly minish-like
design of the figure and tears of the
Kingdom this figure being both hylia and
epicori has to somehow be possible but I
digress because we're currently standing
firmly in speculation station what do
you guys think is it possible that not
only is this figure hylia but hylia was
a member of the pcori race or is this
figure not hylia but is a picori or is
this all utter nonsense in the this
figure has nothing to do with hylia or
the pcori and is instead just a new
currently unknowable being let me know
in the comments below and hey thank you
so much for watching it felt good to
make a Bonafide wild Theory after doing
a lot of lore breakdown recently so if
you enjoyed the watch or at least my
efforts into the making of it please
consider leaving a like and make sure
you subscribe if you're not already to
stick around for more gaming lore huge
thanks as always to my Bandit crew of
which I have the new names of Aang's
137y and John B to thank and welcome you
guys are all amazing and make the
channel possible that's all I've got for
this one so be sure to follow me on my
socials and I'll see you next time this
is Bandit looking forward to tears of
the kingdom and signing out peace
[Music]
thank you